eyes on three crashes right now we start
in the west side this is on the western
beltway heading southbound before lake
mead
looks like crews are still on the scene
blocking some left lanes no big backups
but some minor delays as those drivers
approach the scene of the crash
this one over in the east side is still
there partially blocking the
intersection at stuart and pecos
it's off the 515 but very close to it
just keep that in mind if you're headed
for that area this one just popped up
just a few minutes ago this is right at
craig
indicator we have a fire truck there
responding to the scene las vegas fire
and rescue looks like north las vegas
police there
a situation going on it looks like it's
a report of a crash but again it is
blocking part of that intersection
at craig and decatur looks like they're
moving the camera to show
a little bit more of that scene but just
keep that in mind in case that's part of
your morning commute
we stay in north las vegas where we have
ongoing lane closures on the i-15 both
directions between craig and cheyenne
it was building up the traffic volume
just a little bit but again
no big delays in that area one more
check of the highway system thankfully
shows
no red on the map so no major delays so
that would be great news if you're about
to head out the door
anytime soon alex back over to you